[Música]
especialmente ilusión estar aquí porque
es la primera vez que me invitan para
hablar de algo que no sea técnico ni
nada relacionado con mi entorno
profesional solo por eso doy gracias a
todo el equipo porque realmente me hace
más ilusión yo voy a hablar un poco más
de mi lado personal de algo que quizás
pues la gente me conoce como personaje
público pero no conocen la parte más de
dentro así que es la primera estuve
hacer esto o sea no sé cómo salir pero
espero que bien yo os voy a hablar de
cómo hace años descubrí que cambiando la
actitud y poniendo un poco de
creatividad en nuestra actitud las cosas
mejoraban conseguía alcanzar las metas
que yo tenía en la vida de forma más
efectiva y sin caer en la monotonía fue
un gran cambio
de hecho la creatividad es una de las
cosas más hermosas que yo he vivido en
mi vida ser creativo nos ayuda a estar
despiertos nos ayuda a salir de nuestra
zona de confort a no caer en la rutina y
la monotonía que son una cosa muy muy
dañina es algo que te va corrompiendo
por dentro y te va apagando y te va
apagando
los problemas que tenemos que cuanto más
mayores nos hacemos esa creatividad nos
la van matando nos van matando de hecho
en la escuela yo creo que es el primer
momento en el cual poco a poco no nos
educan para impulsar ese tipo de
creatividad os voy a poner un ejemplo de
que todos nosotros somos creativos es
decir la creatividad no es la artista
todos nosotros como seres humanos
tenemos el potencial dentro para
utilizar esa creatividad pero qué pasa
pues si nos fijamos en lo que nos rodea
pues a veces no abunda la verdad y a mí
me entristece personalmente hay cosas en
el día a día que podrían ser más
creativas y no lo hacemos caemos en la
rutina os voy a poner un ejemplo alguien
de aquí es autónomo
vamos os voy a contar lo que yo creo que
es lo más abrió todas las facturas y no
de las facturas hacer facturas es como
este para una persona creativa hacer
facturas es la antítesis de todo esto
así que un día decidí yo no quiero pasar
bien no pues que hago pues lo que decidí
fue mira la forma en que me comunico con
la gestoría de la empresa de mi
management que me gestiona sin decir
nada pues lo voy a cambiar así que
decidí llegarle el siguiente email
dejarme mirarlo
sin avisar pensar que hay una relación
más o menos formal profesional así que
puede pensar que pensaba en que estaba
loco pero decidí enviar este mail o la
hermana aquí tienes la factura bendecida
y libre de pecado reza tres padres
nuestros para que el pago se haga
correctamente yo que es una persona que
no se me conoce por ser muy religioso
todo lo contrario soy más de creencias
del universo pensé para ya lo suelto
aquí porque era un personaje pues que me
cree para enviar facturas
obviamente yo me esperaba pues como jeje
aquí la tienes gracias no sea algo
formal la verdad es que lo que me
sorprendió fue su respuesta fue
increíble
me dijo hola hermano que dios te bendiga
en hacer una factura más así con la
fuerza de dios la puede reenviar y te
pagan al llegar
y yo me quedé como ostras yo esto lo
hacía para pasármelo bien yo escribí
cuenta que esa persona también se lo
pasaba bien y de hecho pues fuimos
cambiando los personajes pues no pues
vamos con un día pues era al comandante
star wars y le mandaba ya me lo pasaba
bien y con convertir algo cotidiano en
algo que pues me lo pasaba bien y además
me motivaba porque cada vez tenía que
cambiar los personajes otro caso hace
poco fui a actuar andorra pasada por
delante de un bar y me fijé en un cartel
que estaba escrito a mano que ponía se
vende cerveza más fría que el corazón de
tu ex
ya vamos a probar esa cerveza porque un
tío que se ha inventado eso se tiene que
haber una energía pero vamos increíble
dices ostras que bien pues que no sólo
eso podemos implementar creatividad en
nuestros problemas familiares también
extra que me fascina me gusta muchísimo
es una familia que tuvo una hija que con
tres años fue unas personas más jóvenes
del mundo en ser diagnosticada pues con
esquizofrenia
cuando nació su segundo hijo pues los
brotes fueron a peor y además tienen un
problema que es que temían que ella
pudiera hacer daño a su hijo pequeño
aparte de poderse hacer daño a ella
misma obviamente cuando fueron creciendo
la niña se poniendo más grande cada vez
tenía más fuerza y el peligro se
acentuaba así que los padres tuvieron
una idea genial los médicos decían que
había que internarlo que era mejor pero
ellos se resistían a hacer eso así que
decidieron oye por qué tenemos que vivir
una casa grande con 34 habitaciones
cuando podríamos vivir pues en dos
apartamentos pequeñitos uno con cada
habitación que estén al frente del otro
así no tendríamos la habitación del
hermano pequeño
apartamento normal y en el otro
tendríamos el apartamento para jan erik
y aparte evitaríamos cuchillos y
utensilios con los cuales ella se
pudiera hacer daño y pudieran hacer daño
a su hermano y no sólo eso que aparte
tuviera una brillante idea de decorarlo
como si fuera al hospital psiquiátrico
para que así cuando ya nadie tuviera que
acudir al hospital se sintiera como en
casa que consiguieron consiguieron bajar
el estrés familiar porque porque podían
estar toda la familia junto y no había
peligro de que cogiera nada y no sólo
eso es que ya nadie demostró mejoras en
sus brotes porque cuando estaba en el
hospital se sentía como en casa y sus
brotes mejoraron hay también artistas
que le sacan otra vena creativa
por ejemplo la esquizofrenia de un
artista que me fascina seam aphex twin
afecto en una entrevista dijo uno le
preguntaron qué opinas sigue pensando
que la esquizofrenia es una cosa
positiva para la música y él respondió
pues claro dos mentes son mejores que
una
una persona que tiene un genio en la
entrevista también decía cosas como odio
al público o no he sacado música en 10
años porque no quería que mi mujer se
quedara el dinero vale pero fijaros la
genialidad que es que incluso ganó un
grammy y no fue a buscarlo para qué es
un genio no no le hace falta yo en mi
etapa temprana descubrir la verdad que
mi pasión descubrí con desde que tengo
conciencia yo sabía que quería ser
músico y productor musical con 5 años 6
ya ya lo tenía claro así que con 7 años
pues ya empecé a componer música con 9
intenté a hacer música con ordenador y a
los 11 tuve mi primer sintetizador a la
vez que empecé a pues al conservatorio
de música pero me di cuenta de una cosa
y era que cuando tocaba piezas de los
otros no no me sentía igual de cómodo no
sacaba toda esa fuerza interior que
tenía que cuando componía porque pues
porque no tocaba piezas de los otros me
da cuenta que tocaba las emociones de
los otros que a veces si podían estar en
sintonía con lo que yo sentía pero a
veces no y obviamente el conservatorio
te hacen tocar lo que tocas
y esta semana tienes un sentimiento
diferente
voy a voy a componer entonces lo que
hacía básicamente era me sentaba ante el
piano con 11 pero tenía 11 años empecé a
comenzar en pues improvisar entonces era
lo que lo que me salía
[Música]
y
e
[Música]
a
y
[Música]
o
a
si seguiría pero esto lo hacía como
terapia no era lo que me tocaba hacer ni
mucho menos yo iba componiendo y luego
sacando porque aparte esto es una cosa
que si no la podéis quedar dentro se lo
tenemos que sacar sacar sacar de hecho
creo que en las escuelas se debería
motivar a hacer esto no no entiendo
porque la verdad no no nos motivan
de hecho de no hablar aquí de la
creatividad de cómo afrontar la vida de
forma creativa y es que las emociones
son el impulsor de nuestra creatividad
es una causa-efecto tenemos emociones
pues tenemos el potencial para ser
creativo es una cosa que de verdad no me
va a cansar de impulsarlo es que es la
única manera
de hecho yo siempre digo la típica frase
de coachers las emociones son la
gasolina de vuestra creatividad y fueron
pocas y típico pero es que es la verdad
es una cosa maravillosa que hay que
disfrutar
e
voy a poner otro ejemplo
otro ejemplo de cómo la creatividad
puede ayudar por ejemplo en un problema
escolar otro otro ejemplo una niña
pequeña con cáncer no
se tuvo que someter a quimioterapia ni
americana esto pasó hace unos años y la
escuela los compañeros de clase y los
profesores tuvieron otra idea brillante
y fue que en el primer día de escuela
cuando llega regreso
compañeros de clase profesores y madres
se raparon la cabeza en modo de
solidaridad eso es utilizar la
creatividad de una forma positiva eso es
energía eso es lo que debemos impulsar
salir de nuestra zona de confort se nos
mata nos va nos va ahogando nos va
ahogando
también la creatividad tiene una parte
muy mala que es la de la crítica el
miedo al rechazo porque porque cuando
nos sacan de nuestra zona de confort y
exponemos nuestros sentimientos también
lo típico puede haber un rechazo puede
haber no puede haber esa discrepancia en
lo que tú quieres conseguir yo siempre
digo que que para mí el éxito porque al
final la creativa también se hace es el
perón se asocia un poco al éxito no
porque parece que pues eso estas pues
este equipo deportivo o este jugador
pues ha recogido mucho éxito éxito de
ventas éxito de esta startup a todo eso
pero eso para mí no es el éxito el éxito
es tener coherencia con lo que tú
piensas con lo que haces y con lo que
consigues eso es éxito y muchas veces
ese éxito no es el que tú entorno espera
ni el que la sociedad te impone qué pasa
cuando nos exponemos así pues que hay un
miedo al rechazo y eso obviamente es la
parte más dura de ser creativo y la que
tenemos que olvidar al final es una
terapia yo esto lo utilizo como una
terapia
también cuando empecé mi carrera como dj
que es como la gente con un dije
productor es lo que la gente más me
conocía
una vez me conoce también quería hacerlo
de la misma manera así que lo que lo que
hacía era pues robar emociones del
cierre hacia todo tipo de cosas que me
podían ayudar a encontrar la inspiración
de hecho en una de las canciones que
saquen en un disco hizo una cosa que no
había hecho nunca y era que me saqué una
grabadora en un momento en el cual yo
estaba cortando con una novia que tenía
en parís en un día lluvioso y con un día
bueno vamos idílico nadie traslapar y
sensación del amor y fijo entre con todo
lo contrario una ruptura pactada un día
gris y de lluvia así que lo que hice fue
sacar el móvil y sin decir nada me lo
puse aquí y estuve grabando la última
media hora que pasé con ella ya vivía
muy lejos sabía que no nos íbamos a
volver a ver porque había 10.000
kilómetros de distancia así que luego
esa grabación me la puse en casa me la
puse en casa y me ayudó a inspirarme
a crear
[Música]
esto lo podéis encontrar en el disco no
no me lo guardé para mí lo puse en el
disco y luego me inspiró a crearla lo
que daba título al disco
[Música]
y esta podría ser un efecto sonoro esta
lluvia no está es la lluvia real de ese
momento
[Música]
bueno se llamaba to love we say goodbye'
que quiere decir amar hasta despedirnos
y es que las ideas son magníficas las
tenemos que aprovechar y si tenemos una
idea genial una emoción lo que sea
apuntarlo jazz en el móvil la tablet lo
que sea lo que os sentéis más cómodos
pero no dejéis perder esas ideas en
color el bar que tenemos por aquí hemos
hecho muchos proyectos pero básicamente
todos empiezan con lo mismo una idea
pues por ejemplo zero gravity band
me acuerdo que con al ver lo que nos
plasmamos la idea de cómo sería el arte
fuera de planeta tierra la idea no es
hasta es emoción que sería lo que
hicimos fue plasmaron un pdf y no sólo
se quedó ahí
lo hicimos fue crear el proyecto luchar
y conseguimos crear un proyecto que es
maravilloso se llama cero creativa y lo
que hace es
revisar cómo son los impactos culturales
que tiene el ser humano cuando viaje
fuera al planeta tierra y este largos
periodos de tiempo en gravedad cero que
haya volado
vale un papel se queda ahí es que no
conseguimos hacer un vuelo parabólico y
componer música en gravedad cero
conjuntamente con astronautas que habían
estado en la estación internacional
espacial no solo eso que también creamos
otro proyecto se llama martí ficial muse
que es como la inteligencia artificial
puede ayudar en procesos creativos pero
eso se da para dar para otras charlas la
verdad
y luego queda un gran tópico
el amor
cursi para algunos pasional para otros
pero es unos grandes tópicos y una de
las cosas que más mueve porque si
decimos
las emociones son el combustible de la
creatividad pues a lo largo de la
historia el amor ha sido la gran
inspiración que ha tenido el ser humano
para crear muchas de las grandes obras
que se han hecho grandes proyectos
grandes logros ha sido la gran fuente de
inspiración
el amor
como hemos visto anteriormente tiene un
potencial increíble fijaros en los
padres con la hija con esquizofrenia
fijaros en los compañeros de clase los
profesores las madres con esa niña con
cáncer y fijaros el amor que le ponen la
gente que ha encontrado su pasión no las
grandes cosas que han creado eso es
gracias al amor en mi caso cuando tengo
un sentimiento así la verdad que me pasa
lo de siempre que es que tengo que
sentarme aquí y sacarlo sacarlo lo que
hago es me siento intentó sacarlo y voy
haciendo una terapia es como si te queda
por dentro esto te corrompe
[Música]
i
a
y
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
cómo
[Música]
dejo aquí
esto no me quita el tiempo y eso es que
me está mirando y ya me pasa el tiempo
si tuviera que hacer algo incluso un
final de como miro hacia el mundo me
mira hacia el mundo yo sigo con la misma
premisa que es que hay que mira al mundo
de una forma creativa o sea creo que si
ponemos pasión a lo que hacemos si
tenemos la suerte de haber encontrado lo
que nos gusta está pues ya sé que suena
como un [ __ ]
disfruta con lo que hace es que suerte
porque verdad o sea pues si has
encontrado pues disfruta muchas veces
hay gente pues que no ha encontrado lo
que lo que le apasiona yo lo que hago es
que mira su interior porque quizá tiene
un potencial dentro enorme va a ser
emociones que no las ha sacado y quizás
de esta forma podría conseguir encontrar
su pasión
bueno espero no haber sonado como un
coach barato y ñoño pero es diga de
verdad que es la forma en la que yo miro
al mundo muchas gracias
[Música]